herzlich willkommen zu diesem video neue
und zwar in der regel folgen nach bayern
in dieses kinderzimmer das ist übrigens
bedeutet genutztem er ist ein bisschen
und auf gewalt bevor ich je gefahren bin
hat mir geht diese packungen drucken
also mit jedem ja jetzt dass gerade hab
mir gedacht ja gut das kann ich dann
einfach und dann habe ich gedacht ich
kenne das ja auch kombinieren
diese drohne hierunter dass ich mir ich
nehme das alles machte mit irgendwie
passen nebel kassierte die auch immer
auf jeden fall besuchen manchen kassen
nebeneffekte mit dem top preis zu machen
und mit fernlicht und dieser drohnen
kassen selber effekt zu machen grund
mich dann darauf zu photoshop mich an
ich überlegt für insgesamt besser zu
machen indem ich ein bisschen meine
photoshops geldes benutze und mich dann
an entlegenen orten wir sind bereit und
möchte es damit anfangen und
dokumentieren und zwar werde ich dieses
baywa geplant ist es im nachhinein und
seht ihr schon mal was ich machen werde
und jetzt seht ihr wie es machen will
ich habe mir einmal die drohne den
controller wenn dieser qualität bis
hierhin ziemlich schlecht war dann tut
es mir leid das lag daran dass ich
vergessen dabei mikrofonen rauch zu
machen auf die kamera auf jeden fall
geht es jetzt los wir haben hier wie
gesagt verschiedene sachen und ich hab
mir überlegt so hat sich auf jeden fall
einen schwarzen hintergrund brauche und
dafür nehme ich diesen alten fernseher
dann brauche ich auf jeden fall auch
licht und hier habe ich einmal eine
tageslichtlampen jetzt sie weiß noch
nicht ob ich die als einzige lichtquelle
verwenden werde allerdings denke ich
schon dass die ziemlich geil aussehen
wird weil die so hin und weiß ist
irgendwie aber ich habe auch noch wenn
wir jetzt mal die tage sind daraus
machen und es wird gerade direktzugriff
diese kleine nacht im moment die hier
und die leute quasi einfach in
verschiedenen farben und man kann damit
auch über die krassen lenz wir das
machen auf jeden fall werde ich dieses
licht auch mit uns wieder mit einbauen
und jetzt werde direkt erstmal das
trocken als auspacken und gucken ob das
denn überhaupt noch die freund ist denn
ich habe es gestern herz von mehr als 30
stunden in mein auto gepackt als ich von
köln losgefahren bin deswegen hat der
vorstand das ist jetzt schon nicht so
das hier gut zu geklärt dass wegen hole
ich das jetzt mal gut ein messer ein
messer habe ich dann ist da natürlich
nicht gefunden
deswegen muss ein porsche bleiben als ob
es immer noch moment wirkt euch das an
es ist einfach immer noch gefroren es
ist einfach nur in diesem styropor und
konnte sich trotzdem so lange gehalten
sodass trocken als ist auf jeden fall
noch ganz was das wichtigste ist
eigentlich und selbst das komplette
video für die katz gewesen so ich hole
jetzt direkt mal warmes wasser was wir
damit vorhaben werden
ich denke dass hier gleich ich habe
jetzt zwei gläser mit warmem wasser voll
und eine große terrasse und ich habe
hier eine kleine schüssel mit bananen
und gurken schreiben in die werde ich
jetzt kaltes wasser gießen und ich habe
vor die so einzufrieren dass man die am
ende amazon im hummer oder irgendwas zu
splittern gehen lassen kann ich hoffe
dass es klappt das sehen wir auf jeden
fall am ende vom video
mir ist gerade aufgefallen dass das gar
kein sinn macht da kaltes wasser rann zu
machen weil wenn ich da was dran macht
dann gefriert das wasser und dann
bekomme ich ja die ganzen sachen gar
nicht mehr raus deswegen tue ich ein
bundesrat name ist oder rein
michael h
auf jeden fall möchte zerkleinert ich zu
keiner das trockeneis meint hier auf
diese plastik klicke ich hoffe das geht
ohne dass ich alles kaputt mache moment
der alte trick leute ich tue es trocken
als hier diese tüte sein sagt
oesterreich meine eltern und mir werden
sie auch denn hey was macht diesen
bestes trocken als granulat hier wo
jetzt noch 2004
wie geil das direkte und den leuten und
umrühren und sie zu kann es mit diesem
liegt hier auf jeden fall werde ich
darüber nochmal einen zyklus darauf
zurückkommen jetzt geht es erstmal an
dies das zutrauen welt und dafür hab ich
hier wie gesagt einmal ein glas wasser
und hierfür den übertriebenen effekt
eine riesige nicht ganz so riesigen aber
eine wasserschüssel ich muss mir
überlegen wo ich überhaupt mal eine
kamera dahin mache ich habe nämlich gar
kein stativ dafür deswegen nicht
irgendwie aus diesem pool hier so legen
und jetzt kommt das spiel hat sie und
ich tue jetzt haben wir nur einen
bereits extrem dampfendes steht trocken
es sieht so gut aus sieht das so krass
aus wie es dampft immer weise so jetzt
haben wir natürlich noch diese großen
schlüssel ist auch so eine riesige
platte denn so leute der kollege blogger
thema noch und jetzt mal gucken was
jetzt passieren das ist doch schön kiel
kassel direkt direkt aus wegen sondern
die betrieben und heftigen dem
chemielabor übertrieben krass ist und es
war sehr sehr gut daher kommt auch noch
mal ein gutes stück
so ich habe jetzt auf jeden fall schon
ordentlich was gestartet war schon
übertrieben krass und die ganzen dinge
heraus kommen auf jeden fall habe ich
hier diese drohne die ich durch diese
szene fliegen lassen möchte und auf die
ich mich in salzburg möchte das problem
das dabei entstehen könnte ist natürlich
dass die rotoren der drohne die den
ganzen rauch direkte weg posten aber ich
denke dafür lassen wir uns nochmals
anfang man sich überhaupt nicht mehr auf
jeden fall werde ich jetzt mit ein
bisschen alufolie quasi soden bin der
begrenzte machen damit der ganze raum
nicht mehr raus stand und wir noch viel
krasser geprägt so leute ich habe jetzt
alles wieder aufgefüllt ich habe jetzt
hier wiederum ins wasser gemacht ich
habe mal wieder bei mir und ich habe ihn
ist das ganze experiment rum eine
alufolie begrenzung gemacht damit
nämlich sich der ganze raucher und
gesammelt und wir dann einen cooleren
effekt für das bild haben so jetzt muss
ich mir noch kurz überlegen wo ich denn
die kamera hin positionieren möchte
sogar jetzt haben wir christian
landschaft und jetzt fliegt am rhein mit
der natur
okay das ist schon mal ein pass aus
ich muss halt niebel aufpassen wo jetzt
ist ihr wichtig aber ich muss halt übel
auf dass wir gesagt damit ich nicht
irgendwie in dieses wasser rein fliegen
oder haltestellen im kurs
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und der ganze raum
[Musik]
ich hab mir schon etwas weh aber ich
hoffe mal dass wir hinten gut
ausgekommen aber jetzt gesagt es ist
echt so schwer dass er so auf diesem
engen raum zu steuern die kupplerin es
ist jetzt nicht kaputt geht ist hier für
mich gerade schon so klappt in dieser
musik so ich habe jetzt ein cooles bild
allerdings ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen
dass die speicherkarte bei der kamera
mit der ist alles so kommentieren wollte
mittendrin leer gegangen ist deswegen
habe ich das alles nicht auf kamera aber
ich habe auf jeden fall mit dieser
kamera hier genau auf jeden fall ich mit
der kamera ein geiles bild gemacht ihr
seht ja noch den ganzen das muss ich
jetzt alles noch zu vollen das wird
natürlich auch noch richtig viel spaß
sein
auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt ein geiles
bearbeiten wir gern photoshop aber davor
leute davor haben wir noch ein kleines
experiment zu vollenden und zwar geht es
hier um nichts geringeres als um die
kurven entdeckt und jetzt guck ich mal
was passiert wenn ich die ganze zeit mit
dem löffel drauf auch absolut nicht ist
verbringt nicht ist selber zu fest ich
passe es hier los da ist auch noch eine
banane ließ angestellt hat
nichtsdestotrotz möchte gefordert waren
einmal probieren war gut ich hab noch
nie gefahren die banane gegessen
schmeckt echt gut mal gucken wie die
vorne gut geschmeckt
[Musik]
es geht überhaupt nicht meine zähne
haben so geht nicht ich habe direkt über
ganz okay da geht überhaupt nichts
besteht hat zu einem sehr großen teil
aus wasser und jetzt sind wir stärker in
photoshop es gleich so leute da sind wir
schon in photoshop gerade ist er leider
meine aufnahme kamera ausgegangen aber
ich konnte mit der anwender kann man
auch dieses bild machen ihr seht das
hier ist ziemlich cool wir wollen
tatsächlich jetzt muss ich natürlich
noch dafür sorgen dass ich auch in
diesem bild wenn deswegen habe ich
gerade auch ein bild gemacht das habe
ich nicht dokumentiert weil die kielerin
und hier sehen wir das bild und es sie
die ja total provisorisch aus also ihr
seht das hier ist jetzt hier auf dem
bügeleisen wertvoll
während irgendwelche dinge herum legen
also ja das budget war auf jeden fall
hoch an dieser stelle aber ich denke das
wird nicht reichen
die drohne ist ja so leicht schräg und
deswegen hab ich mich einfach ein bürger
eingesetzt damit ich auch so erschreckt
wenn mich ein photoshop ausschneiden die
farben anpassen weil er ein bisschen
rauch darüber legen und dann hoffentlich
ein cooles bilder halten ich zuerst mal
beide sind vor der show gesagt sagt und
habe jetzt hier die ohne jetzt muss ich
mich noch kurz ausschneiden deswegen
stelle ich jetzt eine maske und mal in
dieser maske mit einem schwarzen pinsel
quasi alles schwarz das was später
unsichtbar werden sollte nicht
eigentlich mache jetzt mal ein kurzes
teil davon dann sehen uns gleich sind
du bist die mode mit dubiosen
also leute ich hab das jetzt bei
ausgesetzt und wenn ich mal diese grüne
ebene weg machen dann sieht man schon
dass ich jetzt mehr oder wenig auch in
dieser drohnen setzte allerdings noch
gibt gross bin ich was vergessen und
jetzt skalieren wir nicht mal quasi so
hin das ist irgendwie so aussieht als
wäre ich auch diese wohnen drauf was
welche laut setzen so schön ich finde
sie echt schon überraschend gut aus so
was auch noch fehlt ist so ein kleiner
schatten unter meinem hintern dass hier
nämlich jetzt kannst du auch das werde
ich einmal so drauf gelegt
ich finde das hat auch schon mal sehr
gut geholfen den effekt so ein bisschen
zu verkaufen macht mit pinsel kleiner
und jetzt manchmal wie bei den schulen
noch ein bisschen mehr
man sieht ja auch noch dass ich nicht
perfekt rausgeschnitten bin noch da das
ändert aber auch noch so jetzt habe ich
dann den schatten und in meinem kopf ist
gemacht haben auch bei den grenzen quasi
wollig ausgeschnitten wurde rasch ein
dunkler getan hat damit ich ein bisschen
besser in den hintergrund angepasst
werde
jetzt kommt noch so dinge die
farbkorrektur dann werde ich noch ein
paar einzelne auch elemente einbauen
wenn wir das noch gut aussieht dann
haben wir auch schon das fertige bild
ich das video war so ein bisschen
durcheinander ich musste viel
improvisieren das mit dem bügeleisen ja
klar das war jetzt vielleicht nicht
unbedingt die beste art das zu machen
aber ihr seht es ist trotzdem ziemlich
cooles beck geworden ich habe jetzt
gerade auch nicht mehr eine richtige
kamera sondern wieder meine alten kamera
weil der akku meiner richtigen kamera
jetzt leere gegangen das heißt es sind
halt viele sachen jetzt ein bisschen
rund vorhergesehen gewesen aber solange
das ergebnis stimmt bin ich damit
zufrieden und ich wünsche euch noch
einen angenehmen tag das war's mit
diesem video bis zum nächsten jahr
ja